But the way I solve it, let's first figure out what the units of energy were.
If an E=mc², another energy has units of M x speed--speed is m/s, so L/T,
and since that's squared, we can put a square on both of these.
Now, I don't know why we're telling this too many denominators, so I'm going to write
Energy has units of M¹L²T⁻². Well, this whole term must also have units of energy.
So what I've rewritten is ħ² over something with mass and length squared,
because M stands for mass and x is some distance.
And you know that mass have units of energy, so if move this mass up here
and this L² up there to tell me that ħ² has units of M² L⁴ and T⁻².
Now, let's take the square root, these expos all get reduced by half and I have my answer--1, 2 and -1.
If you got that, I'm very impressed.